hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
among the topics that Arthur
schopenhauer is going to consider in
part three of his on the basis of
morality specifically in the chapter
number 17 on the virtue of justice is
the conception of Duty flicked in German
something that has a very wide scope in
a number of moral or ethical systems but
which schopenhauer thinks has been
misunderstood and in effect misused in
particular by Emmanuel Kant and so he'll
talk at the beginning about the
separation between so-called duties of
Law and duties of virtue more correctly
between Justice and philanthropy which
was affected by Kant in so forced and
unnatural a manner and then he'll talk a
little bit later about duties of law
duties of virtue the latter also called
duties of Love or imperfect duties and
he says this is really not the best way
to make sense out of Ethics or morality
this is a mistake in use of the term or
the concept of Duty and instead for
justice and philanthropy or loving
kindness instead of talking about duties
we should talk instead of Virtues
understood in a sort of architectonic
overarching sense for schopenhauer there
are two fundamental virtues two cardinal
virtues as he's going to call them
Justice and philanthropy or loving
kindness but he also says that these
terms are in the first place at fault
why because they coordinate the genus
with the species what does that mean so
genus species these are ways of
classifying things and the species is
below the genus you could say you might
also call the genus something that is
wider more abstract encompasses more so
the species is something that fits into
the genus for sort of like human being
and animal right human beings are
animals not all animals are human beings
we can say similar things with these
duties and he says justice is also a
virtue and then he says underlying these
terms is the two the much too wide
extension of the concept Duty which I
will reduce to its proper limits so
schopenhauer's conception of Duty in his
view rightly understood is going to be a
lot narrower than what other people make
of that concept of that term and so
when we get to that discussion he begins
by saying this is the place since you
know we're trying to determine the
concept of obligation to determine that
of Duty which is so frequently applied
in ethics as well as in real life and
yet which is given to Great an extension
what is too great an extension it means
that it is used to talk about to apply
to far too many things we should more
narrowly circumscribe or limit this this
conception and he says that how can we
do this well we found that wrong always
consists an injury to another whether to
this per this person's uh Freedom
property honor or their person itself
from this it seems to follow every wrong
must be a positive attack or a deed okay
so so far so good now we're going to add
something to the picture sure which is
going to help us see what duty is he
tells us that
there are reactions whose mere Omission
the failure to do them leaving them out
is uh a wrong and those are what we call
duties
so the things that we
ought to do in relation to others
those are duties because we can't not do
them without doing wrong to that person
in some way so he says this is the true
philosophical definition of the concept
of Duty
which however is deprived of every
characteristic and thereby lost when as
in all previous morality every mode of
praiseworthy conduct is called Duty and
thus it is forgotten
that what is Duty must also be
indebtedness
so by talking about duties in a very
broad scope and calling anything good
that we would do a Duty or a requirement
or there's a lot of other words for this
and he actually brings them up here Duty
toe Deon in in Greek devoir in French
flicked in German we could also talk
about the Latin officium we could talk
about the you know stoic conceptions of
appropriate acts also translated as Duty
tokate right there's a lot of language
available for this schopenhauer is
saying it's been applied to far too much
we need to narrow it in on exactly this
actions by the mere emission of which
injury is done to another what we ought
to do so that others are not thereby
through our failure to do it harmed so
he says
this tells us another important feature
of this obviously this can only be the
case if the person who neglects to do
such an action has undertaken to carry
it out in other words has bound or
pledged himself
so this is another important
characteristic right
you could say that with every Duty that
we have there's some sort of agreement
that was made some sort of saying I will
do this I pledge myself promise myself
I'm bound to do this I I bind myself
I've undertaken it I've said yes I will
do this sort of thing and so we can see
how Duties are created you know if
somebody comes to me and says to use the
old example going all the way back to
Antiquity here is some money I want you
to hold this uh hold on to this for me
keep it safe in your house and when I
return please give me my money back and
I say I will do that I have now created
a Duty with respect to me in relation to
that person perhaps a friend perhaps a
neighbor perhaps a relative to do that
particular action if he comes back and I
say well I didn't know that you were
going to come back and so I spent it on
magical beans or I gambled it away or I
bought myself a new house or something
like that or even if I do something like
well you know my children needed Medical
Care the money was just sitting there I
spent it on doctors
I violated my duty my obligation to that
person that I've committed to do
and schopenhauer thinks that this is at
the core of most of our duties he says
as a rule this is an Express and mutual
agreement and so he's going to give a
bunch of interesting examples of this
and we'll look at those in just a moment
the other thing that he says that's
particularly important to pay close
attention to
because it might be a little misleading
depending on what else you have read or
thought about when it comes to duties it
says every Duty confers a right now we
ought to think about who is this right
conferred upon and the natural way of
reading this I think for many people
especially since in ethics textbooks or
you know in a lot of other discussions
we say every Duty corresponds to a right
you know you could think about for
example John Stewart Mill and his
discussion of Rights in utilitarianism
and in on Liberty is kind of an assumed
thing that if I have a duty towards you
you have a right to the Fulfillment of
whatever that duty is Right a duty on my
part corresponds to a right on your part
and that's correct but that's not what
tropenhower is actually referencing here
he's saying that by undertaking by
engaging in uh this this performance of
binding myself to an obligation to you
I also have a right that arises from
that and so there's a kind of
reciprocity going on there why do I
undertake a duty in order to get
something on my part I don't just impose
duties on myself for the sheer fun of it
right Society may tell us that all sorts
of things are duties that aren't really
duties because we didn't enter into a
kind of agreement and we didn't get a
right conferred on us as a result
says no one can undertake an obligation
without a motive which here means
without some advantage to himself
and he is going to talk about an
exception to this
we might think about whether there's
other exceptions but first let's look at
the examples that he gives I think this
is quite helpful Prince and people
that's a very interesting one isn't it
he's talking about political Authority
and those who are subject to the
political Authority the subjects have a
duty to the ruler the prin caps which is
what Prince means right the the one who
is in charge
but they have that because the ruler is
supposed to be correspondingly in some
sort of reciprocity doing something for
them protecting them perhaps ensuring
the orderly conduct of governmental
functions who knows what it's going to
be building roads what whatever right
the next one government and civil
servants this is very interesting as
well right because we see and it's not
just in Western Europe and Central
Europe of course we see this also in in
China and many other civilizations there
are a bunch of people who do certain
jobs they're functionaries they work for
whoever happens to be in charge the
actual government are the ones who are
you know ruling and then the civil
servants make sure that that actually
happens and this could be people working
at the Department of Motor Vehicles this
could be teachers who are employed by
the state in some way it could be a
local government it could be the
national government it could be all
sorts of things
we get to more personal relationships
talking about master and servant a
servant is not necessarily A Slave but
somebody who you know belongs to a
household and works for that household
and is governed or ruled or directed by
the person who is in charge
schopenhauer is saying that the servant
has duties to the master but they have
those duties because they're getting
something out of it it's not just well
you took me in war and you let me live
so you get to boss me around and do
whatever the hell you want there's not
duties arising from that sort of thing
then he brings up two very important
professions within a lot of different
societies one of which is is translated
here counsel meaning lawyer the one who
works for you and advises you helps you
out and client and we might extend this
to all sorts of other of professions
your financial planner your life coach
whoever it is that is providing you with
some guidance you should follow their
guidance but
you should do that if it's going to turn
out well for you you have the obligation
balance by your rights in relation to
them physician and patient one that goes
back to Antiquity the very existence of
the Hippocratic Oath which by the way is
not you know the guiding thing from like
say the 20th century onward for most
medical uh staff there's all sorts of
other Oaths and pledges and things out
there but the the idea of there being
this structure in which the physician
has certain duties the patient also has
certain duties they are in relation to
each other and then he generalizes even
further
so we can think about economic uh
exchanges an employer and whoever
undertakes to do something right he says
here we go uh employer in the broadest
sense of the word and everyone who's
undertaken to carry out any kind of task
this also conver confers rights as well
as duties you take on the duties in
order to get something so this is a very
interesting uh feature of schopenhauer's
understanding of Duty as I mentioned
there's one exception to this that he
thinks is legitimate there's there's
other things too that he says eh you
could call those exceptions but I'm not
actually going to consider those
Duty creation right what's the exception
it's a different role relationship
parents to children
he says only one obligation is known to
me which is undertaken not by means of
an agreement but immediately through a
mere Act
since the person with whom it was
concerned was not yet in existence when
it was undertaken okay well that's the
act of you know not to put to find a
point on it getting it on and uh
generating a child right when you
generate a child you now have
obligations to that child you have
duties to that child and what is the
primary Duty that he talks about
whoever brings a child into the world
has a duty to support it until it is
capable of supporting itself and should
this time never come for example in the
case of one who's born blind uh one who
is handicapped one who's you know
lacking the mental faculties and so and
then the duty also never comes to an end
he goes on to say for by the mere
non-provision of assistance that is
through an Omission he would injure the
child and he's not specifying does this
just mean food and water and shelter and
clothing no he's not saying anything
like that it might include you know
providing an education it might include
providing a supportive and loving
environment it might you know provide it
might include all sorts of things that
the parent is supposed to provide and
this all falls within this duty to
support until a time of Independence
now
it's interesting to see that he says
there's no agreement here
and yet the child also has a duty
so he says parents must also have a
right as regards their children and what
is this the basis of the children's duty
of obedience to their parents but later
the duty also ceases so you know until
you're 18 or whatever the age is going
to be established you the parents have a
duty to support the children have a duty
to obey and that ends once the situation
changes and here he said he he examines
something else he says all right so
obedience doesn't have to be there
anymore what should it be replaced by he
says gratitude now is there a duty to
gratitude good question he goes on and
he says
um in its place will appear gratitude
now gratitude for what does every parent
deserve gratitude
no because gratitude is given as he says
for what the parents did over and above
their strict Duty so you know if your
parents for example have a duty to
clothe you and they get you you know
burlap bags and sew them into you know a
uniform that you wear every day they've
satisfied that Duty on a minimal level
uh the fact that all the other kids at
school make fun of you and they're like
look at Johnny sack uh shirts and stuff
like that oh you know they've at least
satisfied the minimum requirement now if
your parents go and making ice clothes
or make the clothes fit well or you know
make sure that you just you don't just
live on hand-me-downs or something like
that I'm thinking for example about my
mother who used to sew us clothes as did
many uh people in that generation
particularly those from the you know
lower to Middle class at that time you
know she really took good care of that
aspect of things I should feel gratitude
for that right because she went over and
above the minimum requirement so
gratitude is for showing benevolence you
could say and she says or he says
um however an unpleasant and even
revolting of Vice in gratitude may be
gratitude cannot really be called a duty
why not
well because you're by not giving
somebody gratitude by not showing
gratitude to them
you're not harming them you're just not
giving them something
extra he says that it's a mission causes
no harm to another hence is not a wrong
moreover the benefactor the one who's
doing the good thing would inevitably be
under the impression he was tacitly
striking a bargain so gratitude can't be
a
a requirement it can't be an obligation
it is something that's good to do good
to display good to have but there's no
actual Duty there he does finish up by
talking about
reparation for harm fixing things after
you've screwed them up and he says
reparation for harm done could be
regarded as an obligation arising
directly out of an action
and then he says not really though as
the elimination of the consequences of
an unjust action this reparation is a
mere attempt to face it something purely
negative resting on the fact the action
itself ought not to have taken place so
there isn't a duty on schopenhauer's
part uh or in his his mind of reparation
itself it is a good thing to do of
course or it's undoing a bad you could
say right but it's not a moral
obligation it's not not a duty and then
he also talks about Equity
um you know as as something that we
don't need to take into account either
so this gives us a a solid sense of what
schopenhauer means by this rather more
restricted and in his view
philosophically correct conception of
Duty or in this case moral obligation to
um not fail to do actions that the
omission of which would cause a harm or
wrong to somebody else